Trí phụ hành cuông 1,5 cộng bụ kể hoạt tăng chỉ tiêu trở xin ngàn í, từ năm 2020,
với mục tiêu cùng có thể thống í tế khu vực í tế thiệu và í tế công.
Với tế cho biết chỉ tiêu xin viên í sẽ tăng mười sau phân trăm và năm 2020.
Lên băng, những năm 2014, cao hơn 147 mươi đến vi, sau khi năm 2020,
và tiếp tục được năng theo lộ trình để đặt băng, tạm chăm bởi mỗi xin viên và năm 2020.
Bố trường í tế dông, nc dông, được tổng thống lý dây em dông bụ nhập.
Hành định kế hoạt được xây dưỡng sau các cuộc thảo lất và chính vụ sẽ thích tụ nối thoại của lây dưỡng trình muốn,
và công chống.
Duy nhiên, hôm qua hành quốc đã chỉ chỉ quy định này là thiêu trình như,
cho rằng các tình đoán về chỗ cầu bác xy í dưỡng ở trên dưỡng lệ ở xa lần,
hiện chưa gió giới bác xy có phân độc gác hòa độc phân đội mười hay không.
Kế hoạt mới được diễn ra trong bố cạnh, kiế ước về khu hỏng í tế năm 2020,
khi đó các địa xuất tăng mạnh chỉ tiêu đào tạo bác xy í,
đã trong gọi cho là sống lình công của hành nghiên bác xy tập sư.
Gây dành đoạn em trọng, hệ thống trong xóc sức quảy trên toàn hành quốc,
mà hệ quả kéo dài cho đến tận của nóm hành nghiệm của trong hành lâm.